now it's time to bring down the biggest
holiday movies and we're going to start
with three other fabulously Charlize
Nicole and Margo are dropping a
bombshell we're all really excited to
share this with the world finally
[Music]
producer Charlize hit up this week's
special New York screening for her film
already off to a bombshell start it's in
the top 5 best limited releases of 2019
7 to 14 million expected this weekend
two Golden Globe and four SAG Award nods
don't do this for the accolades but this
was a parasite project me too let's make
it clear their well-deserved
Charlize prosthetics to transform into
Meghan Kelly took 3 hours every day that
puddy goes into your nostril and they
take a cast of the inside of your
nostril that's what that putty was I
couldn't believe it was her yes looking
at her going I'm gonna be the story as
soon as she started speaking as Megan
she melted away completely it was so
cool to see a progress to what is the
real Megan thing
Kelley Instagram this shot of her six
year old staring at the poster saying it
even confused him the former Fox News
anchor did see the movie calling it an
incredibly emotional experience but she
also pointed out she had nothing to do
with the film and certainly would have
made some edits it can't be easy for her
so I'm incredibly understanding
[Music]